hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and today we're going
to be going over the Godly Gambit which
is a line in the Karo Khan defense which
starts out with E4 and C6 now play
typically continues with D4 D5 and then
after the pawn takes on D5 usually white
would capture on D5 but instead Black's
gonna play Knight to F6 offering up an
additional Pawn here on C6 we are going
to be looking at the accepted just the
pawn takes on C6 black recaptures on C6
you can see anytime your gaming material
you're trying to gain an advantage
whether that's a Tempo a strategic any
of those in this case it's just time you
know how quick we are getting our pieces
involved into the action you can see the
queen and the Knight are both attacking
the pawn on D4 so pretty common now for
white to play Knights F3 simple
development move defending this Pawn on
D4
and black has two options one is to play
Bishop G4 pinning down the Knight
getting the light Square Bishop involved
into the game and the other is to play
E5 I think both are fine and have their
own merits I do think E5 allows for some
trickier positions that white can get
into and I'm always trying to find lines
where white is in a tougher spot so I
think E5 is the play and from here white
has three different options that we're
going to be covering today yes they can
play some other things but we are going
to be looking at the pawn taking on E5
we're gonna look at the bishop coming to
B5 pinning down hour night and then
we're also going to be looking at the
Knight taking on E5
so the first version we're going to look
at is the pawn takes on E5 this opens up
for the Queens to come off the board and
that's exactly what we're going to do
we're going to take with our Queen
the king captures and then we're gonna
play Knights to G4 now this Knight on G4
is attacking the pawn on F2 and you can
see that would be a fork attacking both
the king and the Rook on H1 here
and white has a couple ideas on how they
can defend this
one since they've already moved their
King that they're not worried about
moving the King again so because they
can't Castle they can't Castle anyway
because they move their King to take our
Queen on D1
so they could come back to E1 I don't
think that's as good of a move because
that now blocks off The Rook coming to
the E file which they potentially may
want to uh to do and it doesn't get any
other piece involved into the action
we'll look at another uh move and that's
Bishop to E3 it also defends the pawn on
F2 and gets more material involved into
the game but King that you won they
could try if that's the case we can just
add more pressure to that square with
Bishop to C5 again since we're down to
material we want to make sure we're
getting more Mito involved into the game
and we are on the attack especially if
you're gonna give up your queen that's
typically a very very powerful piece in
an attack when you're down in material
so once that's off you have to even be
more aggressive than you were before so
the Knight and the bishop both attacking
the pawn on F2 I think they pretty much
have to play Bishop to E3 we can
exchange and now we can play Knight
takes E3
we are still uh down a pawn in material
so white has six pawns black has Five
Pawns we can start to attack this Pawn
on E5 yes they have a Defender uh right
now with their Knights but we can Castle
on the king side if we want to we can
Castle on the queen start really start
to put pressure on this pawn it will be
difficult because it is an isolated Pawn
for white meaning they don't have a Pawn
on the F or the D file to support this
so it will be difficult for them to hold
on to this we are also threatening with
the move Knight to E3 we're threatening
this Knight takes on C2 this is another
Fork attacking the king and the rook and
so more than likely they play Knight to
A3 which does defend it but also this is
not where white wants their Knight this
is not involved into the game and so
we're able to develop even more material
preparing a castle on the queen side and
so this should give us ample uh exchange
for being down a pawn in material now if
they don't play kingd1 because I don't
think King to E1 is the play to defend
the pawn on F2 I think Bishop to E3 is
the play again still defends that pawn
on F2 and stops black from playing the
bishop to C5 in this case we can go
ahead and take the bishop the pawn takes
and now we can get our light scrub
Bishop involved into the game we can
Castle on the queen side and so while it
looks a little bit different you can
still see that although we're down two
Pawns in material we're we are going to
be able to chip away and start to attack
these two isolated pawns on the e-file
but it's going to be a longer term
vision
so that is if the pawn takes on E5 the
next thing we're going to look at is if
they play Bishop to B5 which makes sense
getting another piece involved into the
game pinning down our Knight in case we
want to use that and just stop some of
the threats that we have now in this
case I think the best players play
Bishop 2g4 hey you want to pin down our
Knights we're going to pin down your
Knights as well
from here I think you'll typically see
three things one is the pawn taking on
E5
I think you also may see the bishop
taking on C6 anytime you're up in
material it makes sense usually to just
exchange down as much as possible
reaching to the end game if you have a
material advantage usually is a good
thing so just taking material forcing us
to exchange and giving us an isolated
Pawn on the C file and then lastly just
Knight C3 getting more material involved
into the game uh is usually something
that one side may want to do so after
Bishop G4 first thing we'll look at is
the pontics
okay which you can probably imagine as
soon as they take that we are going to
exchange on D1 and then we're gonna
Castle on the queen side this does check
our opponent and so while we don't have
great king safety because both the pawns
on the D and the C file are gone we
don't need as much safety as we
typically would when the Queens are on
the board you can be a little more
aggressive in how you have your king
involved than you do if the Queen's
involved but really we're just looking
for a faster approach to get our Rook to
d8 while also opening up for our other
Rook to get involved into the game
because yes we could just bring our Rook
to the eight but also this allows us to
bring our Rook at some point to the
center of the board and it just does
multiple things by castling on the king
side now they could block it with Bishop
D2 then we take that material on E5 and
now we don't have to worry about that
pin from the bishop on B5 they can't
move their Knight because the pins are
little bit different and if they move
their Knights then that would be an
illegal move so they can't do that so
that's what happens if they take with
their Pawn on E5 they also could just
exchange here on C6 okay we have to take
so it's a little bit different than
before if they take with their Pawn on
E5 which we'll look at maybe if they
just Castle but if they take that's
going to be similar as before we Castle
on the king side maybe if they do this
now we come back to D7 we just have a
different setup than before but this now
allows us to add more pressure on this
E5 Square we can also just come to E8 if
we want to we can get our dark Square
Bishop involved into the game they may
not take on E5 in this position they
could decide you know what hey things
are fine right now we're up in material
by one Pawn we have good structure with
the center so let's just go ahead and
Castle usually if people are going up
against the game but they want to make
sure that their King is safe well in
this example we're just going to go
ahead and take on D4
then we can go ahead and exchange on F3
if they exchange down here we can go
ahead and take with our Knights or
excuse me our Rook on d8 they take on F3
and you can see we're gonna have to chip
away on these pawns on the FL the F3
Pawn is definitely weak and it's going
to be difficult for them to hold on to
this but we don't have a ton of
additional threats so this I think is
fairly good for white going into the
in-game just because they don't have to
worry about a ton yes we're going to get
our dark Square Bishop Dalton to the
game we could potentially Castle on the
king side but not as many threats as I
would typically like when I'm playing a
Gambit
the last thing we're going to look at is
if they don't take on C6 instead they
play Knight to C3 in this case I
recommend just pushing forward with E4
and then if they cast on the king side
we can exchange on F3 I think they push
forward with D5 that's attacking a pen
piece which is usually what you want to
do at night's being pinned down by the
bishop to the king we cannot move our
Knight on C6 because that would be an
illegal move and so maybe we play A6
attacking a bishop now Rook to E1 we
played Bishop D7 preparing to Castle on
the king side so a little bit different
setup when they played Knight C3 we're
usually not castling on the queen side
of the board and exchanging Queens
instead we're gonna play a different
structure so that is what happens if
they play Bishop to B5 early on the last
version we're going to look at is if
they just decide to take with their
Knights on E5
now from White standpoint I think this
is one of the better options so if
you're playing this as white and you run
into this I think taking on E5 is
definitely a good play here now there's
a couple options that black has I think
the most logical one for them is just to
take with our Queen on D4 forces the
trade on D4 we take with our Knight on
D4 you can see that we're threatening
the pawn on C2 forking the king and the
Rook White's usually going to play
Bishop to D3 I say usually because they
could play some terrible move that does
not uh end up being that the same
situation just know that I'm showing
what's typically the the best move or
the main line if you see something
different there's usually something
going on and you can take advantage of
that in this case we can play Bishop to
F5 trying to just blow that up if they
take we can take back here on F5 but
then if they play Knight to C3 it's
difficult in my opinion to really get a
big Advantage from black yeah we could
just come back with Knight to D4
attacking that pawn but then they could
just play King D1 they don't have to
worry too much with the Queens off the
board as far as castling is concerned
you know from black standpoint yes we
can castle if we wanted to at some point
uh probably not going to right now need
to hold on to the F7 Pawn but yeah we
can castle at some point we can get our
darsh corbish involved into the game
Castle on the king side if we really
want to but all in all I think it is
going to be difficult for black to
really have a strong Advantage once they
take our e-pawn the e-pawn is just a
huge asset in this Gambit from black so
that is an overview of The Godly Gambit
hopefully you guys enjoyed definitely
try it out and let me know what you
think but thank you guys so much for
watching this video
I will see you in the next one